[Music]
microbiological agar is an important
material used in cultivation and
isolation of microbes this video will
show you how to prepare potato dextrose
agar or pdm
pda is a microbiological media used for
wide variety of fungi
pda can be prepared using ready-made
dehydrated media
or also can be prepared using fresh
potatoes
thanks to the helping hand miss aubry my
postgraduate student for assisting me in
preparation of this video
this is already met dehydrated pda
the media consists of 200 grams of
potatoes
20 grams of the extra sugar and 15 grams
of agar
we will resemble the composition for
preparation of pdf from fresh potatoes
as mentioned earlier the pdf consists of
potato dextrose and agar
for preparation of one liter of the
media we need
200 grams of fresh potatoes 20 grams of
dextrose or sugar and 15 grams of agar
however we increase the agar from 15
gram per liter to 20 gram per liter for
more solid agar media
for the purpose of this video we will
prepare 250 milliliter
therefore we need 50 grams of fresh
potatoes 5 gram of dextrose and 5 gram
of agar
[Music]
after that the media need to be
sterilized using an autoclave
miss aubry will demonstrate how to use
the autoclave
[Music]
you